one day and I'll remember remember
everything that happened the good the
bad those who survived and those that
did not
fantastic I mean I wish it wasn't a
farewell party it's the last piece in
the puzzle of a very long journeys it
will be the last time you see
middle-earth on the big screen this was
the last move in a master plan a plan
long in the making
from war IMAX is an extraordinary
experience reforms in this go it's
really the best way to see them it's so
nice of so long please if you feel you
are surrounded by middle out it's a
phenomenal experience the minute it
finishes I wanted to watch it again
you know I had people all find it
exciting go different vibe to the other
two you started this you will forgive me
if I finish it when they see the Battle
of the five armies they will realize
that this is a unique and extraordinary
piece of filmmaking it's just none stuff
it's so action-packed
everyone thinks battlefields is
astounding in Lord of the Rings this is
another little change you have piece
this movies but it thrills and spills in
3d it's a climatic end to an enormous
story that's the celebration it's a
great send up the entire movie is the
climax from start to finish you have
about one question to us how this day